[Musique]
et c'est parti pour le conseil de classe
de kelly b d'aurélie une élève qui cède
alors intégré à la classe dans les cours
de musique grâce à ses capacités de dj
sétois km 1 tu avais tu te fout du monde
kelly tu vas travailler gens qui étaient
déjà des jets mais toujours pas ça avant
de rejoindre la table petit à petit vous
apportez vous étiez dehors après vous
étiez là maintenant vous êtes là bas la
planète
un transfert qui aura permis à baba de
faire pas mal d'économies en revendant à
bon prix son bureau sur le bon coin je
vais le mettre sur le bon coin et sur
chedjou sur ebay tout ça on va le vendre
j'ai dit une élève au fort caractère qui
n'hésite pas à se montrer insolente avec
le professeur vous savez qu'ils avaient
des musées florence a bien sûr on s'est
donc fait à votre niveau vous défaire à
1070 vous n'êtes pas si grand c'est la
chape aujourd'hui
une élève très doué en eps surtout quand
il s'agit de lancer
[Musique]
ah ouais quand même
[Applaudissements]
et si kelly devait être résumé en un mot
ce serait gastro selon les estimations
de l'om est kelly aurait été plus mal
être cette année que l'ensemble des
français dit qu'elle y est encore malade
qu'il y aujourd'hui hélas pas là on
parlait dans un endroit non je n'ai pas
envie d'être la flore intestinale un
petit peu fragile dès qu'elle arrive sur
pas d'âme
elle arrive à gaz pour aller au bout
j'agis comme on a eu peur je vais
checker des védrines a alors qu'elle
note pour kelly
[Musique]
c
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on l'a perdu écoutez je suis on va les
vendre sur le bon coin bravo avec kelly
avait brabo franchement belle corée au
final j'ai rappelé britney chiche danser
dans les bars mais devant aller quel
événement attention sur twitter donner
une note à teddy avec le hashtag des pmp
kelly et bien sûr vous le savez est ce
que vous voulez qu'elle y reviendrez
motion ou pas il ya la jauge qui va
bouger bouger bouger bouger
on va bouger bouger réaliser les magic
system allez on va démarrer par benjamin
castaldi
alors qu'elle est très bonne élève très
fraîche très drôle
vous la voyez bien qu'elle allait très
bien il est prêt à les prêts très
fraîche très drôle mais mais qu'elle est
que d'insolence que d'un sonar est
beaucoup trop d'insolence je te rappelle
que tu as commencé il ya deux ans et que
tu manque vraiment de respect pour le
patron et ça je ne le supporte pas et je
ne le supporterait plus jamais bravo
donc pour que tu redescendre et on me
l'ont un peu rude et gonfle nommé un
très beau 3 vous l'avez fait pour moi
j'en avais marqué voilà merci alors à la
haye jimmy mohamed à vue et qu'elle y
écoute dans les points positifs
en fait tu es la bouteille d'oxygène de
cyril on se rend pas bien compte mais
taylor gens soutiendront bessette et
benhaim c'est à vous êtes une béquille
c'est ma bulle d'oxygène goûter
god cyril toujours sur son dos sur ses
côtes et ça reste embêtant thackeray que
c'est embêtant
oui tu as quitté ton emploi fictif de dj
pour enfin être autour de la table et je
trouve que tu as nettement plus la place
autour de la table
tu travailles pas beaucoup voire pas et
ça se voit pas donc je trouve que c'est
un talent c'est plutôt plutôt
intéressant et tu arrives à regarder des
émissions qu'on trouve tous bizarre par
passion alors que pour nous c'est un
vrai raz sera dans les points négatifs
je trouve que tu as du mal à regarder
les émissions lorsqu'elle commence très
tôt le matin et du coup tu es souvent
décalé lorsqu'une émission commence
après 15 heures c'est impossible pour
toi de regarder souvent tu oublies que
tu es sur un plateau télé tu penses que
tu es sur un simple salon de manucure
mai dernier point c'est que tu as autant
de légitimité de parler de médias que
benjamin de fidélité je trouvais la
meilleure note que j'ai mis jusqu'à
présent et je pense que je n'irai pas
plus haut pour les autres jeux de
messages et beau
valérie bénaïm beaucoup ce que vous
pensez de cette jeune fille aux cheveux
blancs elle n'aime pas ma job dit en
coulisses c'était de leurs mots en fête
alors vous attendez beinheim d'abord la
leur mais makeli j'assiste à l'éclosion
d'un papier sur wii non c'était dans un
petit cocon tu étais au fond derrière
cyril ont pesé pas toujours aussi laid
ce n'était pas tête at-on desk assez
timide tu quasiment pas la parole
on voit là tu n'osait pas y aller et
petit à petit tu t'es dit je m'en fous
leblond ne fait pas peur j'en ai rien à
faire tu la ramener même quand on te
demande pas tu la ramènes est de mieux
en mieux et est même on l'a dit tu m
aimes insolente même tu réponds à série
et ça tu sais que ce n'est pas 100 me
sur me plaire et en plus on l'a vu là à
l'instant comme dirait s'irriter d'arc à
thury tu vas tu danses tu fais tu joues
tu tu joues tu t'amuses avec nous en
revanche nom est tu es devenu légitime
autour de la table voilà petit à petit
on passage est très légitime
en revanche été trop émotif d'être au
premier degré parfois il faut que tu te
plantes faute d'arriver à comprendre
voilà atteint à maîtriser au mieux en
métal papillon mais pour tout ça est à
jour de progression je te mets ainsi
miley malus maillard il n'ya que mighty
malaisie très jolie kelly vdev ni je
pense que la table de tpm petton statut
de chroniqueurs te vont comme un gant
effectivement tu n'es plus dj tels eu un
avant et un après djette et moi j'adore
ton ni respect j'adore son insolence
auprès de la blonde
j'aime je proposerai un goût de rappeler
d'abord tué espiègle tu es joueur tu
nous votre ambiance heures c'était un
vrai regard sur les choses sur les
médias est une sorte de bouffée d'air
frais je trouve et autant doc et notre
doudou et pour moi tue notre mascotte
alors un seul bémol c'est pour ça que
j'ai pas mis la note maximum tout [ __ ]
au tac bio dès que tu ne mets plus de
musique
non je déconne je t'aime bien est
médecin lui
moi tu arrives à la parole et vous a
donné la parole
mais j'ai senti que vous aviez peut tout
chanter mal un mois déjà tu le vois pas
non mais s'est alors mêlé c'est mon
kényanes n'ont pas encore pas encore
alors là ça fait isabelle savez quand
maroquinerie nkili c'est un des plus
jolis sacs paix soit effectivement kelly
c'est la plus jolie peau le tpm fait ça
va sans dire et j'ai qui est chez kelly
même attendri tout ce qui m'exaspère
chez les autres c'est la génération qui
arrête pas de se prendre en photo et qui
fait du placement de produit ça
m'exaspère chez elle ça me touche
elle traite de 9,2 vieux évidemment tout
ce qui dépasse 30 ans il ça m'exaspère
chez sam attendri et elle fait moins les
nourritures spirituelles que la bouffe
qu'elle a dans son assiette et chez elle
ce sont 7 10 20 bref alors plus sensée
essence et là c'est tout j'ai fait un
bonhomme est un auteur c'est une jeune
femme qui même que j'aime beaucoup
simplement si tu pouvais arrêter de
m'appeler mais minou tout le temps
du coup les autres se croient autorisés
à faire la même chose ça ça me sur
gonfle résultat je vienne beaucoup gt
masters 1000
il comptera jean michel maire alors elle
a su faire oublier les platines
elle est coquine mais bonne frangine
divine mais bonne copine elle illumine
et pour du moins vers les marchés ms pia
au point faible je dirais que ont peu
faible c'est difficile de te trouver un
point faible je dirais que tu es parfois
effectivement un peu sensible voilà tout
simplement et en point positif
tu as eu vraiment trouvé ta place
données des analyses et être pertinente
ou s'ils ont des sujets et aux et
parfois moi je n'ose pas et toi tu oses
et c'est ce que j'admire chez toi et
pour tous âges comme michel lancien oui
kelly chouchoute à la place la plus
difficile autour de la table parce que
la plupart des gens diront que tu aurais
durant un ton rôle de danseuse dans
belle à d'autres diront qu'une potiche
d'aller jalouse qui diront que t'as rien
à faire ici tu auras les machos les faux
culs qui te font croire qu'ils
n'appartiennent à aucune des quatre
premières catégories
quand tu retiens tu sais à ce
pratiquement plus que mathieu cyril et
moi qui te trouve merveilleuse merci
voilà et tu es encore là on parle en
leur nom vous maintenant bah oui
compliments comme ça fera plaisir
compagne et y voir là donc c'est la
preuve que t'as pas vendu tonton aval à
l'offre télévisuelle tu es restée la
même
avec simplicité avec humilité avec
joyeusetés donc l'année dernière je
t'aurais mutins parce que tony milliard
à taux cette année mapon des amis dont
je te mets un très beau 7
jean-mi ayvaz dit matthew ma fille des
marais derrière cyril pour finir devant
crois moi j'aurais adoré faire inverse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est tragique pour moi merci la blonde
alors arrêtez de ma pub non plus ton
arrivée a fait beaucoup de bien parce
qu'il fallait une jolie fille dans
l'émission est à vous est arrivé samedi
à naples 1-1 but d'animer les vigies
rabin et la vallée magnifique piscine
toile est pas un cran au dessus mais je
ne l'espère boyer delphine aussi qui est
magnifique si vite et ça ton problème
c'est qu'après c'est ça ton problème
c'est ça alors je vais là là en revanche
notre sérieux deux secondes
il ya trois choses la première tonte à
beauté pour de vrai ça va être ton pire
ennemi parce que justement les gens vont
te juger là dessus il faut que tu
apprennes à ta musique est un petit peu
parce que je vois bien que tu prends un
petit peu des coups de tapes thomas
c'est un petit peu fragile sortir les
missions et tout ça et fera émission qui
est difficile donc à moulins photo ft un
peu une carapatte un peu plus fort après
c'est sûr et puis aussi autre chose il
faut que tu te sentes légitime à noter
autour de la table quand tu dis quelque
chose d'aller vite vite et à légitimité
pardon ne viendra que de toi sans toi
légitime et tu deviendras son coeur je
t'adore et j'étais mis la note de 8 et
ça peut mieux carré
[Applaudissements]
alors jean et qu il peut faire un truc
où il a toujours rien compris
alors alors alors si non mais tu
appelles crapaud m pas du tout à fait
trois quatre lignes 3 4 8 chez lui alors
je compte sur toi
1 2 3 4 5 ça veut pas dire que je monte
sur ton dos et que je compte sur toi tu
fais partie des gens en qui j'ai
confiance
avec qui on peut construire sans faire
attention on va faire de grandes choses
ensemble ou non mais il faut qu'il y ait
de l'amour entre nous du coeur je n'ai
jamais entendu ces dix conseils de
classe je vais essayer rêver novelli je
n'ai pas de critiques que la
compréhension
tu sais que je t'aime et que je ne peux
pas te dire des choses qui te fasse du
mal alors c'est signé bruno est aussi
deviner qu 10 sur 10 mai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est la seule personne pour qu'il a
vraiment travaillé
ouais ouais alors light ils sont aptes à
médis milan pense pas il a confondu
conseils de classe et speed dating la
mort d'amour est arrêté que l'amour
d'amitié je regarde ma note pour toi là
voilà merci
les conifères 7 sur nice mais plutôt
6,82 6e sur 10 si je devais de 80 des
personnes par vol pour avoir les trois
chaînes séance pour cent plus que
matthieu delormeau merveille la demande
contre le fait qu'on veuille tourner à
table je suis quelques mois un gros
pourcentage voir c'est vrai un sermon
mais vous êtes un des préférés
bah oui de la personne la blonde à
plaisir j'aurais envie de dire une
connerie